Eyes are really weird when you think about
them.
They’re like little gel filled sacks sticking
out of our faces.
They take all these wavelengths of light and
somehow make pictures out of them.
But how did they evolve to be like that?
Hey seers Julia here for DNews
Eyes are extraordinarily complex.
And the theory of evolution posits that such
complexity arose from the process of natural
selection over millions of years.
But extraordinary claims demand extraordinary
evidence.
So how did eyes evolve?
Well with each generation of offspring having
slightly altered eyes with ever increasing
improvement, that gave them a decisive advantage
over predators and peers.
Back when life was just a bunch of cells in
a soup, eyes probably got their start in bacteria
over 600 millions years ago.
A random mutation gave some bacteria a collection
of light sensitive cells.
These cells helped the bacteria know how bright
sunlight was.
And some bacteria, who could sense this light,
moved away from it, which helped them since
bright sunlight also carries harmful UV rays.
After a few more random mutations these little
“eyespots” as they’re called turned
into a kind of early eye.
Early eyes, if you can even call them that,
were just a collection of cells called photoreceptors
with photosensitive cells with proteins called
opsins.
They lay on top of the photoreceptor and catch
photons coming into the eye.
They trigger a series of chemical reactions
that causes the photoreceptor to send an electrical
message towards the brain.
Their appearance in the tree of life can be
traced back more than 580 million years and
can be found in everything from jellyfish
to insects to dogs and humans.
One study published in the journal National
Review of Neuroscience found that evidence
like this “strongly supports the notion
that a common ancestor of sea-squirts and
vertebrates possessed...many of the building
blocks that are fundamental to light signalling
in our own eyes.”
And we can see some of this process happening
in the fossil record.
We can find evidence for early eyes in fossils
of trilobites, a marine arthropod, that lived
around 543 million years ago.
As in most cases of evolution the delicate
balancing act, or should I say arms race between
predators and prey, drove the evolution of
the eye.
So you’re probably wondering, how could
we tell what their eyes looked like, eyes
don’t fossilize well.
And you’re mostly right, except trilobites
had a type of bacteria in their eyes that
laid down a thin layer of minerals.
And it’s these traces that we can see, but
only with super high powered x-rays.
According to a study published in the journal
Science Reports, trilobite eyes looked like
flowers.
Under a lens, their sensory cells are shaped
like petals, surrounding a photoreceptor.
While basic, these eyes served well enough
for these bottom of the ocean dwellers.
They worked so well in fact, a relative of
the trilobite, the horseshoe crab, still has
them.
As time wore on, the arms race drove the evolution
of more and more complex eyes.
Rather than looking for fossilized evidence
we can examine the eyes of modern animals
that haven’t changed all that much.
Take a look at the turbellarian worm.
Their eyes are more like little cups lined
with pigment cells.
These cells are opaque and don’t let light
pass through, so they act as a way to direct
light towards the photoreceptor cells.
After a few more years of evolution, the eye
cup becomes more of a chamber and the opening
narrows.
This shape allows greater ability to tell
where the light is coming from and an early
way to form images of shapes and things.
This is called a pinhole eye and can still
be seen on primitive animals like the beautiful
nautilus.
Along the evolutionary way, animals evolved
spines and skulls, and with it, their eyes
got more advanced.
According to a study published in the journal
Nature Reviews Neuroscience, researchers found
we could trace our own complex eyes all the
way back to early lamprey-like vertebrates
who lived over 500 million years ago.
Their eyes start to look more like how we
think of eyes.
A lens forms from a thin layer of adapted
epithelial cells covering the opening to keep
out infection.
They even have a retina and ocular muscles
that allow for eye movement.
These eyes would have been able to form a
simple image over a broad range of wavelength.
But there was a problem.
These eyes evolved for living in water.
Once our ancestors moved onto land, our eyes
needed to evolve again.
Around 430 million years ago, according to
a study published in the Journal of Experimental
Biology, tetrapod eyes took on a more elliptical
shape to compensate for seeing in the air
rather than water.
And the development of evolution even decides
where eyes are located.
For instance prey like deer tend have their
eyes on the side of their heads so they can
keep a watchful eye out over nearly 360 degrees
for a predator.
And predators, like wolves, tend to have eyes
on the front of their head so they have depth
perception.
All the better to hunt you with my dear.
So our eyes aren’t perfect and evolution
isn’t a perfect process.
But as Charles Darwin said “from so simple
a beginning endless forms most beautiful and
most wonderful have been, and are being, evolved.”
[FHP PUSH]
Hey Guys, if you like the shirt i have on
and want to check out other DNews shirts be
sure to go to the link below.
We have a ton of cool science shirts for your
buying pleasure.
AND if you’re a first time buyer use the
promo code DNEWS for 10% off at checkout.
So speaking eye ball weirdness, ever look
up at the sky and see all those strange floaty
bits?
WHAT THE HECK ARE THEY!?
SHOULD I BE WORRIED ABOUT THEM?
Trace has the whole scoop in this episode
right here.
So eye balls how cool are they?
Thumbs up this video if you’re think they’re
as rad as I do.
Subscribe to this channel if you want more
rad science and always leave a comment down
below.
Anything else you’ve wondered about?
Ask us down below and we might just answer
it in a future episode!